so my name is Chelsea Cooper and I am an
SVP and Oscar health the insurance
company I'm sure you've seen the ads
during Oh II around New York and I
oversee our members strategy and
operations there so I've married a Scott
and one of my favorite expressions that
they use in the UK is back yourself
and it and it refers to essentially a
play that you run when you're when
you're playing rugby and you can't quite
get the you can't quite pass make a pass
and instead what you do is you take it
and you run it down the field yourself
and try to score and if you think about
if you think about that there's a lot of
meaning packed into that it's about self
confidence
it's about advocate advocating for
yourself it's about really leaning in
and being fearless and everything you do
so we've heard some incredible
incredible stories tonight from these
women and while I don't know many of
them well I've got to imagine that they
will have had to really live eat and
breathe that phrase those two words back
yourself in order to get to where they
are today so when I was 8 years old
growing up in a place called Worcester
Massachusetts also known as the whoo for
folks who are from there Adam Sandler
used to do a little spoof on Worcester
but growing up there I changed schools
and and within a couple of weeks of my
new school I found myself being I found
myself as the new target for the school
bully every day when I walked into class
I could really count on and Rena to call
me names pick on me all the things that
that that bullies do and when you're
that young those interactions that you
have mean it's your whole world I have
two kids now two babies now and I see
how those interactions that they have at
school really impact everything they do
so so those moments when I was little
like really
mattered and so every day I'd go home
you know crying and and really quite
upset and and hope that the next day I
would have the courage to stand up and
this went on and on for a long time for
about four years and one of the things
that still haunts me to this day is that
at that time I didn't tell my parents I
didn't really I wasn't comfortable
telling my teachers but more more
importantly I didn't I didn't have the
courage to really stand up for myself
well fast forward a few decades and I
started working for a new company a new
job and we were doing well I had a new
team we were kind of killing it and and
I remember my boss coming to me male
boss and you kind of sitting me down and
saying you're you're doing well you're
doing really well and I want you to take
on all these other additional
responsibilities and I remember having
kind of that inner sort of stomach ache
and thinking oh man I don't I don't know
that I can do this and it was so clear
and in that moment that he really
believed in me and I think somebody else
kind of shared a similar story but he
believed in me more than I believed in
myself and and so was was really
advocating for me even when I didn't I
didn't have that yet so one of the
things that I found myself doing more
and more though over kind of middle of
my career was was was finding those
opportunities to start advocating for
others and I don't know why it is that I
found it easier to advocate for others
but then advocate for myself and I think
it's something that is women we do a lot
of and so I there were all you know
there were a number of moments I can
think about where I would see talented
women and you know one comes to mind in
particular where I was working in a new
role with a new team and I had someone
who was maybe a little less confident a
little shyer on the team
in fact she was powering all of the like
analytics and dashboards that one of the
the men on my team was actually getting
credit for and when I kind of dug in and
uncovered it and and realized pretty
quickly how talented she was I just kept
on putting more and sort of more on her
plate she probably didn't thank me for
it at the time but but putting more and
more on her plate it was because I just
totally believed in her and it was it
was kind of that same thing that I had
seen from my male boss years before
believing in me and so I would shove her
to speak in front of her whole company I
would shove her to go have lunch with
our CEO and I would shove her to talk to
our leadership and and it it really I
think you know helped her and ultimately
she just crushed it as I knew she would
and and I thought the company was really
better off for it so so I found myself
advocating for others but really there
was a sort of pivotal moment when I just
through sort of all caution to the wind
and and just decided to just kind of go
for it
I was mu I moved back to London for
business school I had married married a
Brit and I was going to London Business
School and maybe about six months in an
old friend from San Francisco got in
touch with me and he is us-based
ride-hailing app was taking off uber and
so Travis asked if I would help first
year at Business School if I would help
launch Guber in the UK I said remember
going out to dinners with him over the
course of I don't know four or five
months trying to introduce him to many
other friends that could do this for him
and said look I just moved here I've got
my life I've just got married I'm
starting business school sort of no
thanks and and finally at one point sort
of towards the end of my first year I
ended up you know kind of going out and
finally
was convinced that I should do this and
I just said you know what I've got
Business School
but I've also got this great opportunity
I don't know how I'm gonna do it but I'm
just gonna do it and I'm gonna do both
and so over that summer between my first
and second year I launched uber in the
UK and then during my second year of
Business School was running it while
also juggling a sort of full course load
and it was that moment where I was
incredibly like nervous I didn't know if
I could do it all of those things that I
just said screw it I'm gonna just go for
it and it was one of the best sort of
learning experiences I've had and and
fundamentally changed the way that I
think about things and so I guess from
sort of my my if I could leave folks
here with one thing it's when you find
that that like stomach ache those like
inner feelings that are telling you
don't do that thing or there's no way I
can handle it
especially the women out there those are
the times that you have to lean in and
you have to just jump in both feet and
really go for it and also if you notice
folks around you who again especially
women don't have that on their
self-belief that's when you have to I
don't even think it's pulled them up I
really think it's about shoving them
shoving them telling them they gotta
they gotta do it I don't have an option
I mean the women on my team know that
way they know and I'm I'm just kind of
forced them to do things but altum Utley
they come back and they're better off
for it I think I'm better off for it and
actually I think our our companies that
we work for are much better off for it
so thank you all
you